pour qui souhaite vivre dans une île
déserte il importe d'abord de s'arracher
au collier de briser les liens qui vous
retiennent encore votre chien et vous
sinon à la société du moins aux îles de
la société
alors seulement vous découvrirez une
ivresse du large
vulgairement connu sous le nom de mal de
mer et l'ivresse de la découverte
lorsque vous arriverez en vue du paradis
terrestre que le destin vous a retenu
lille s'appelle et yahoo
elle est située au nord de l'archipel
des marquises près de l'équateur défendu
par des murailles verticale de 600 m
longue de 13 km est accessible par très
beau temps seulement dans une baie
caillouteuses et peuplé de requins dit v
vas y toi
[Musique]
mais accessible à qui il faut être
bagnard chercheurs de trésors ou
légèrement farfelues merci pour
s'installer dans ce désert où la seule
trace de vie et la ruine d'une prison
sur laquelle quelques gardes chiourmes
désaffectée a inscrit for rent
c'est-à-dire à louer
[Musique]
mais enfin nous y sommes et nous y
sommes pour un moment alors construisons
d'abord un abri car dans la plus grande
solitude la solitude demande encore à
être préservé nos soucis immédiats sans
la est allé à nos pieds le chat
ati sont les poules à la tête desquels
blue cela favorite la callas et enfin le
compagnon de toujours
eder le chien tout ce petit monde qu'il
faut nourrir et qu'attendez-vous des
miracles car plus vous êtes seul plus on
a tendance à vous prendre pour le bon
dieu
alors pour améliorer votre ordinaire de
riz et de lentilles vous décidez de
devenir agriculteur premier problème
faire suivre de tahiti une tonnes de
gravier le gravier est incomparablement
plus fertiles que le caillou deuxième
problème protéger vos cultures
éventuelles contre les moutons les
cochons et les poux troisième problème
qui vous concernent aussi directement
trouver de l'eau pour vos salades et
pour vous même justement un filet d'eau
sale coule au fond du ravin
cette eau magnésienne n'est pas potable
vous pouvez du moins vous ils avaient et
ont oublié quelques secondes qu autour
de vous il fait plus de 40 degrés vous
pouvez y faire votre lessive et votre
décèle souci essentiel d'un homme seul
que votre prédécesseur l'illustrent
robinson crusoé
il n'y aurait systématiquement vous me
direz qu'il était anglais mais ça n'est
plus une excuse
[Musique]
les légumes refusant obstinément de
pousser dans ce climat
vous irez chercher votre ravitaillement
ailleurs
[Musique]
vous serez obligé non seulement d'aller
très loin mais encore d'en revenir et
cependant la bonne surprise de cette
randonnée car il ya une bonne surprise
dans le sac
la bonne surprise sera la découverte
d'un régime de bananes mais vous
découvrirez également qu un bananier ne
produit qu'un seul régime de bananes
quant au montant que vous avez ramené
n'en parlons pas trop un mouton il faut
d'abord le tuer ce qui est écoeurant
il faut le transporter sur des
kilomètres il faut le vider sous le
soleil
il faut le dépecer il faut le découper
heureusement qu'il ya les poules et les
mouches pour profiter de tout cela
aux problèmes que pose la préparation
d'un mouton le cochon on ajoute un
supplémentaire
il est nécessaire de rappeler sans poils
et pour cela de l'ébouillanter lorsque
vous disposez d'une théière et d'un
canif leurs attelages d'un cochon
devient un sport d'éclore
quant au poisson n'en parlons pas il est
empoisonné alors que faire sinon
attendre et gratter c'est plus attendre
que le pacifique que daigne se calmer
pour aller à la quête de la seule ou à
peu près potables celles que l'on peut
trouver à marée basse dans un trou sur
le récif sur un temps doucement et
enrichie de tout le sel que les vagues
viennent lui ajouter celles que l'on
trouve sur le récif à condition que le
temps soit favorable que la marée soit
basse que le récif soient dégagées ce
qui est exceptionnel
et pourtant cette eau aussi salée
qu'elle soit il vous en faut en moyenne
cinq à six litres chaque jour de quoi
vous dégoûter de l'eau pour le restant
de vos jours de l'eau oui mais de la
solitude est bien de la solitude n'ont
d'ailleurs la solitude n'existe pas il
n'ya pas besoin d'aller si doigts pour
découvrir que tout ce qui vous entoure
vie un désert a une âme et le soleil les
pierres les racines aussi et c'est une
bien grande vanité de la part des autres
hommes de croire que l'on est seul
parce qu'on est privé de leur présence
[Musique]